[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof hello Martin good day
Walter how are you doing ah I'm doing
well and you I'm still okay yeah
lies upon lies what is this fellow here
behind me well it links into lies upon
lies doesn't it yes it does
okay so let's look at lies from a
Biblical perspective and not only that
from a salvational perspective it's very
important well of course yes because
there is a Great Deceiver isn't there
yes and he's a liar
from the beginning and I'm concerned
because God has given Humanity a
commission
to go and expose the LIE
so if you are said or warned don't be
deceived it means don't believe the lies
don't believe the lies so what is a lie
and what is it all about
and basically we're going to show two
videos and people will say well what has
that got to do with lying
well the lies actually concern an
individual
yeah yeah
because the one who is denigrated and
lied about
is what this book is all about it's our
book uh it's called the revelation of
God it's a whole revelation
on the light that has been spread
about the son of God
so when it comes to the Son of God and
somebody wants to put him down
is actually
practicing a lie
perfectly put you see the problem is the
great controversy
started off because of a lie because of
a lie so
if the Bible
is a book that testifies of an
individual and Jesus said
these are they referring to the
scriptures that testify of me of him
so very important that we understand
that so any religious system
that downplays
Jesus Christ
or the role of Jesus Christ
is actually practicing a lie that's it
and everybody that believes what they
teach
if it's not in harmony with scripture
believe lies believes the lie so let's
go and jump into this with a Bible study
and start off with the news
broadcast now this news is very
interesting let's look at it and see
what it's about
Conservative Christian leaders are
calling on prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu to stop a bill proposed by
members of his coalition to make it
criminal to tell people about Jesus in
Israel our Jerusalem correspondent
Daniel Cohen is live near Tel Aviv with
more good morning Daniel good morning
Allison good morning everyone a big
story just before days before Palm
Sunday Good Friday and Easter sacred
time for Christians two ultra-orthodox
members of prime minister netanyahu's
Coalition have introduced a bill that
would punish Believers for sharing the
Gospel of Jesus with prison time United
Torah Judaism knesset members Moshe
Gaffney and Yakov Asher introduced
legislation last week making it illegal
to share in conversation or produce
content online in print or by mail their
explanation of the bill emphasizes a
warning to stop Christians in particular
the punishment one year in prison or two
years for sharing with someone under the
age of 18. Joel Rosenberg is the host of
the Rosenberg report and editor-in-chief
of all Israel news he's also a Jewish
follower of Jesus
obviously Jewish people don't agree with
Christians evangelicals or others about
who Jesus is right we all know that
there's a theological difference but
Evangelical Christians and and other
Christians have been so supportive of
Israel and the Jewish people so to
silence to muzzle and gag even Israelis
like myself and others to say you can't
talk to another person about your faith
and why you believe it that is terrible
that is not freedom
although he doesn't agree theologically
Netanyahu has always been a strong
friend of evangelicals speaking at
meetings and believing freedom of speech
and freedom for Israel's small Christian
Community uh should be protected now
should this bill gain traction it could
spark a serious clash with the 60
million evangelicals in the United
States and 600 million around the world
Gaffney first introduced a ban on
evangelism in 1999 it went nowhere
United Torah Judaism is in a stronger
negotiating position now though since
Netanyahu needs to keep the party in his
Coalition or it could threaten
netanyahu's ability to remain in power
the bottom line is that Orthodox Judaism
rejects Jesus Christ flat out according
to the scripture if you do that you are
following a lie that's it
so this is not an indictment this is not
anti-Semitism this is just a statement
of fact it's fact
it doesn't only affect Judaism it
affects any religion if you take Islam
Islam denies the Divinity of Jesus
Christ
it accepts him as a prophet
but no higher than any other prophet and
especially not higher than Muhammad
by denying the Divinity of Christ which
is scriptural you are actually following
a lie and then you fall in the Trap of
it but is it only religions that
classify themselves as non-Christian or
let's say is it only in non-Christian
countries that they would consider
legislation like this what about a
country like the United States not
everybody is a Christian there but it's
a Christian Nation
by and large
well here's an article from the 23rd of
March Utah School District considers
Bible ban under new sensitive material
law
this particular School received a
petition from a parent to have the Bible
removed from schools for being what the
parents consider a sex written book
Utah parents United left of one of the
most six written books around the Bible
you'll no doubt find that the Bible has
no serious values for minors
because it's pornographic by our new
definition the petition read
well they have some other words about it
as well it talks about explicit sexual
material it talks about
masturbation intercourse sudden me Etc
all of those things are banned but he
says the Bible is
full of such details but there's one
slight little difference those books
that are being banned promote this
activity the Bible condemns it they say
in this document that the Bible
has infanticide that the Bible has a
genocide that the Bible has all of these
things in it as well
which are contrary to prison culture
but these were judgments of God
and they were typological of a judgment
to come
so isn't that the duty of the minister
of the Gospel or anyone that believes
the gospel to warn Humanity well that is
the commission that God gave us correct
so they will not be able to say one day
but you never warned us no no they
especially because
then if you don't do the warning the
blood's on your end okay now
if the Bible is truth
and you ban the Bible then you're
Banning truth and propagating what lies
lies it's as simple as that so it's a
very serious issue lying is a very
serious issue
you know what and even if you just want
to suppress it say for instance for
ecumenical value we suppress it you are
endorsing the lie you will be at least
suppressing portions of it yes that is
selective reading but that's also like
supporting life that's lying yes telling
a half truth
is no less a lie than telling a complete
falsehood that's it
well let's have a look at what the Bible
and the spirit of Prophecy have to say
on this issue John 8 32 says and you
shall know the truth and the truth shall
make you free
in other words Martin if you do not know
the truth
you are in bonded bondage yes
so the truth will set you free from
bondage
doesn't that include the Refuge of Lies
yes now we spoke about lies in our last
one
there were many many lies that were
being told because the narrative
constantly changes and you cannot have
two narratives that are opposed to each
other standing next to each other's
truth right no
okay sanctify them through thy truth Thy
word is truth
so if you ban the Bible you're Banning
truth then you are living a lie so would
you say that humanity is by and large
living a lie yes all right here's a
quote from The Acts of the Apostles
wherever the truths of the Gospel are
proclaimed those who honestly desire to
do right or led to a diligent searching
of the scriptures
if in the closing scenes of Earth's
history those to whom testing truths are
proclaimed would follow the example of
the bereans searching the Scriptures
Daily and comparing with God's word the
messages brought them they would today
be a large number loyal to the precepts
of God's law where now there are
comparatively few
but when unpopular Bible truths are
presented many refuse to make this
investigation in fact modern they said
get rid of the Bible nobody wants to
study the scriptures anymore
though unable to controvert the plain
teachings of scripture
they yet manifest the utmost reluctance
to study the evidences offered some
assume that even if these doctrines are
indeed true it matters little or whether
or not they accept the new light and
they cling to pleasing fables which the
enemy uses to lead Souls astray
thus their minds are blinded by error
and they become separated from Heaven is
that a serious issue
if you want if you're going to be
separated from Heaven it's the most
serious issue that in your life it has
Eternal consequences
so lying and Truth stand in opposition
to one another
the comforter is called the spirit of
Truth his work is to Define and maintain
the truth
he first dwells in the heart as the
spirit of Truth and thus he becomes the
comforter there is comfort and peace in
the truth but no real peace or Comfort
can be found in falsehood mutton is the
world in a state of peace and comfort no
it's constant chaos everywhere but they
want to bring about peace and safety but
without truth without truth so can it
work no no it cannot work
it is through false theories and
traditions that Satan gains his power
over the mind
we've looked at some false theories in
the last few episodes right and how it
affects people's minds
[Music]
by directing men to false standards he
misshapes the character through the
scriptures the Holy Spirit speaks to the
mind and impresses truth upon the heart
thus he exposes error and expels it from
the soul it is by the spirit of Truth
working through the word of God that
Christ subdues his chosen people to
himself Martin this is so important it
is through the word that he works and
not through performance and feeling
if the word is excluded then you must be
sure that it's a lie
I think even in the Garden of Eden a lot
of what happened there was accompanied
by feeling
even in the in heaven when this whole
thing started he he was agitating the
feelings of the Angels yes and that made
a third of them follow him
there's another quote from testimonies
to Southern Africa which is an
interesting what at this time when great
light is shining from the word of God
making dark Mysteries plainest day
is the day of mercy of Hope of joy and
Assurance to all who will be benefited
thereby to all who will open their minds
and hearts to the bright beams of the
son of righteousness but there is an
opposite class to this those who will
not come to the light who despise the
truth because it exposes error and
transgression and sin
and as a result the brevity and boldness
and transgression is becoming all
pervading this is what's happening on
the world stage
you can see it the more they don't want
to hear the truth the more agitated they
get the more aggressive and the more
everything is going to ruins and they
love the LIE they love the LIE they
cling to the lie because the the LIE
Comforts them in their transgression
exactly I that was what I was just
thinking the transgression and sin that
is being exposed
that is the manuscripts volume 9 Christ
draws a sharp distinction between the
world and his followers
and yet that distinction is becoming
obliterated this is a very dangerous
thing to happen
and instead of the church converting the
world the world is converting the church
when the church walks in the light as
Christ is in the light she will maintain
a high ground as a representative of our
Lord and be chosen of God and faithful
the comforter is the spirit of Truth in
false theories we have a deceptive
perversion of Truth but there can be no
genuine comfort in falsehood the spirit
of comfort is the spirit of Truth which
exposes error calls it by its right name
and expels it from the soul
truth does not exalt finite Humanity but
glorifies Christ this is so important
these are they that testify of Me Jesus
said
and anything that shall make them or
Eclipse Christ is a falsehood what's a
falsehood something that is not
elevating Christ and it's a lie it's a
it's a lie it must be a lie so you've
got a little bit of a problem in your
ecumenical movement yes let us take home
to ourselves the question
am I receiving and properly
appropriating the light given me of God
in his precious word
this is interesting Martin so the church
is compromising
and allowing the World to Change it and
we've seen that this is happening
throughout the world Martin we are
living in a time of Crisis is this a
time to compromise no especially now you
should stand like Daniel is it is it now
a time to embrace a little bit of a lie
no not one tenth of it okay so God's
people according to Psalm 60 verse 4
have been given a banner thou has given
a banner to them that fear thee that it
may be displayed because of the truth
so God's people have been given a banner
a standard and you must hold the banner
High the standard is the law
and the Sabbath of course is a sign or a
banner or a Mark that says I want to
adhere to the whole of the law and not
to allow a teensy-weensy little portion
of a lie to come into my relationship
with Christ precisely this fellow on the
screen at the back here
he's very good at that right
sneaks in sneaky
Proverbs 23 verse 23 says by the truth
and sell it not also wisdom and
instruction and understanding truth and
error
truth and lie cannot stand side by side
the one exposes the other
so let's ask ourselves what is a lie
now I chose to get the definition here
from Webster's Dictionary the 1828
version because it was still written by
godly people
not like some of the modern ones where
you get the very strange definitions
that no longer qualify as definitions
true they actually have circular
reference most of it circular reasoning
as well
so lie is a noun it's a criminal
falsehood
a criminal offense to lie at least
towards God right it's amazing it's a
criminal falsehood a falsehood uttered
for the purpose of deception
an intentional violation of Truth
fiction or a false statement or
representation
it is willful deceit that makes a lie a
man may act a lie as by pointing his
finger in a wrong direction when a
traveler inquires of him his road so it
doesn't even have to come out of your
mouth right you can be lying just with a
look do you think there's many false
pointing our fingers these days in the
wrong direction I think the road marks
have all been twisted around then
actually you should go there
all right so it's a fiction in a
ludicrous sense it's a false Doctrine
quoting 1 John 2 verse 1. but the Pope
says we shouldn't talk about Doctrine
an idolatrous picture of God or a false
god according to Romans 1 25 mutton an
adulterous picture of God or a false
representation of God Is A Lie yes that
which deceives and disappoints
confidence
quoting Micah 1 14. to give the lie to
charge with falsehood a man's actions
may give the lie to his words
very interesting so this definition I
think is pretty complete and it brings
in the spiritual aspect Yeah so
basically anything contrary to the word
of God is the LIE yeah
right here's the definition of the word
lie as a verb the previous one was a
noun
to utter falsehood with an intention to
deceive or with an immoral design
that has not lied to men but to God acts
5 verse 3.
this is when they withheld a portion of
the money remember yeah
to exhibit a false representation to say
or do that which deceives another when
he has a right to know the truth or when
morality requires that just
representation
this is so fitting because in the world
today as we've seen they want to take
away the Bible
then you are taking away truth that is
deception that is one of that is
probably the deception that
above a lot of others
it's absolutely horrendous
now if it is the truth and you suppress
it you have become a liar
the Bible clearly defines who the liar
is the serpent was a liar from the
beginning right
so the devil is a liar that's it in John
8 44 ye are of your father the devil and
the lusts of your father you will do he
was a murderer from the beginning
and Abode not in the truth because there
is no truth in him when he speaks a lie
he speaketh of his own for he is a liar
and the father of it
whether it is an individual
whether it is a system whether it is a
government
if they suppress any portion of the
truth or want to introduce legislation
to suppress it
they are lying yes they are of their
father the devil that's it it's very
serious that
So What proportion of humanity and how
many governments fall into that category
I think unfortunately most
there might be an individual here or
there within a government that doesn't
fall in that category but if God is
going to sweep them all away it means
they all fall into that category you see
that part of a country
fell away when Jesus said I leave it
unto you desolate from there on there
won't be a specific country anymore no
so what makes the devil a liar what
makes him a liar well let's have a look
at some of the points one John 1 10. if
we say that we have not sinned we make
him a liar
and his word is not in Us in other words
if we don't recognize our condition
but actually we want to propagate our
condition
then we are liars you know it also I
think it also falls in there you must be
careful for I'm just only human
I'm only human therefore I can do this
you might say I have a weakness God help
me help me
but once you say that a certain Behavior
which is unscriptural
is actually acceptable no even
commendable then you've become the chief
of liars
1 John 2 verse 4 he that says I know him
and keepeth not his Commandments he's a
liar and the truth is not in him well
that makes the papacy a liar because
they have not only changed the
Commandments of God they teach others to
do the same yes they actually boast
about it and they want to have worldwide
legislation
to honor their Commandments over and
above God's commandments so that makes
them Liars
okay
or 1 John 2 verse 22 is a liar but he
that denies that Jesus is the Christ
now this is a serious issue this is
where because this makes most of the
world religions fall right out of the
bus
and
unfortunately the people that don't come
out of that are accepting the LIE
they're they're buying a lie and have to
face the consequences he's Antichrist
that denieth the father and the son
so this relationship father and son
If you deny it
you're a liar
one John 4 20 if a man say I love God
and hates his brother he is a liar now
there's a more difficult one
for he that loveth not his brother whom
he has seen how can he love God whom he
has not seen now God sent his son so
that whosoever should believe in him
should not perish but have eternal life
so if God so
loved the world that he was prepared to
make this great sacrifice
then we should love our brothers and
sisters right
well 1 John 5 10 he that believeth on
the son has the witness in himself he
that believeth not God has made him a
liar because he believeth not the record
that God gave his son
but this is serious so a large portion
of the world
qualifies as Liars
it's sad it's sad and we've been given a
commission to preach the gospel
and now they introduce a bill which they
probably won't pass but they introduced
the bill that means that this is a
mindset
that to preach truth
is an offense yeah
but to practice a lie is commendable
commendable that's sad
all right let's ask the Bible
Who Lies well we all lie right yeah but
let's just get some specifics do worldly
people lie Psalm 62 verse 9 surely men
of low degree of vanity
and Men of high degree are a lie
to be laid in the balance they are all
together lighter than vanity so Martin
from the lowest to the highest
and they're all in trouble
so when we say say that men of high
degree are a lie
do we see it in politics yes do we see
it in the medical world constantly do we
see it in science yeah what about
Evolution we just discussed it the whole
world lives a lie is this the only lie
that we are being taught or are there
lies that we know nothing about yes I'm
sure we've swallowed quite a few lies
what is learning against learning the
Jesuit school model is based on a lie it
is well
terrible thing to say so you go to
school all those years to learn a lie
well didn't you say you actually had a
doctorate in lies well you have to have
certain muscles of Truth scheduled with
lies
all right Psalms 119 69 the proud have
fought the LIE against me but I will
keep thy precepts with my whole heart
so here you have this double connotation
if you keep the precepts there will be
people that will turn against you yes
it's a promise
all right so if you're sitting in a room
with people that insist to smoke in the
room and you are the only non-smoker who
is the troublemaker you you're the
Troublemaker it's always like that if
you try and do the right thing
you're the Troublemaker I mean just just
take it to that one the trouble of
Israel yes
Proverbs 14 verse 5 a faithful witness
will not lie but the false witness will
utilize
it's it's not a maybe no it will it will
now how many false Witnesses have we had
on the screens lately
hundreds how trustworthy are they then
how can you follow their science
and we follow it like sheep
Jeremiah 16 verse 19 O Lord my strength
and my Fortress and my refuge in the day
of Affliction the Gentiles shall come
unto thee from the ends of the Earth and
shall say surely our fathers have
inherited lies vanity and things wherein
there is no prophet
so there will be people that realize
here towards the end when the Gentiles
come into the kingdom of God that they
have inherited lies they've been lied to
particularly in terms of Salvation
that's it people will start waking up
and that is
um
thankfully because God doesn't give up
on anybody no all right so the world
lies to you what about religions even
Christian religions do they lie
Jeremiah had much to say about it and
you know as we discussed before Jeremiah
is a type of the Three Angels messages
yeah
even word for word it is flee from
Babylon come out of my people it's all
in Jeremiah right correct that's why I
made that sermon a while ago approaching
Doom he was the prophet of Doom because
he always spoke of everything that was
coming but if you pull it through to the
remnant today it's exactly the same it's
exactly the same
so he lamented this fact Jeremiah 27
verse 9 therefore how can not ye to your
Prophets
nor to your diviners nor to your
dreamers nor to your enchanters nor to
your Sorcerers which speak unto you
saying you shall not serve the king of
Babylon who is he talking to
to Israel is talking to God's people and
he's saying that there are diviners and
dreamers and enchanters and Sorcerers
which are speaking to the people and
those prophets and diviners are inside
the church they're inside their with the
right the true prophets as well
unfortunately we don't have that problem
today
there's a little bit of irony and I
think yes there's some irony in it yes
Jeremiah 27 verse 10.
for they prophesy a lie unto you to
remove you far from your land
and that I should drive you out and ye
should perish
this is a serious issue
do we have Liars
do we have people that prophesy a lie in
our churches today how many wins of
Doctrine yeah
we've spoken about it you've got lying
profits
that are prophesying
and it doesn't come true yes then you've
got prophets like fauci who's a prophet
of science but falsely so-called science
for I have not sent them says the Lord
yet they prophesy a lie in my name that
I might drive you out and that you might
perish ye and the prophets that prophesy
unto you this is also a very serious
issue beware of anyone
that makes Jesus less than he is for
example
or God forbid makes him a created being
Jeremiah 28 15 then said the Prophet
Jeremiah to hananiah the prophet here
now hananiah the Lord has not sent thee
but thou makeest this people to trust in
a lie
so it even mentioned specific
individuals
or Zechariah 10 verse 2 for the idols
have spoken vanity and the diviners have
seen a lie and have told false dreams
their comfort in vain therefore they
went their way as a flock
Daniel 8 12 and a host was given him
against the daily sacrifices added there
by reason of transgression
and it costs down the truth to the
ground and it practiced and prospered
what who's he talking about he's talking
about
let it alone he's talking about the
little horn power and the reformers made
no bones about it they said it was the
papacy that's it
so when he does this when he throws the
truth to the ground then what is he
doing
then he's practicing a lie yes but he
prospered under that lie yes because
everybody's believing it everybody loves
the lie that word wonder they actually
wandered after the LIE yes Romans 1 25
will change the truth of God into a lie
and worship and served the creature more
than the Creator who is blessed forever
amen Martin Luther takes that verse and
says that Paul is referring to the
papacy okay and it does the same in
Thessalonians of course where he talks
about the one who elevates himself to
the position of God within God's Church
to the law unto the testimony if they
speak not according to this word it's
because there is no light in them that
makes them Liars Martin
Proverbs 28 verse 9 he that turneth away
his ear from hearing the the law even
his prayer shall be Abomination that's
very very straightforward what does that
do to The ecumenical council where they
trample on one of the precepts of God
namely the fourth Commandment exactly
and so but what does this do to
Universal or communical prayer movements
it's an Abomination according to the
verse
Amos 2 verse 4 thus says the Lord for
three transgressions of Judah and for
four I will not turn away the punishment
thereof because they have despised the
law of the Lord
have not kept his Commandments and their
lies caused them to ER after the which
their fathers have walked that's pretty
straightforward
so lying
is very Broad
and it's part of society
it's part of institutional law well like
we've mentioned before if you just go
along not to stand out or to be
different you also fall into
a lie the lying
um your category you're part of that you
become part of the lying stream
so this is very very serious so when
they make legislation which
compels you to break one of the precepts
of God they are compelling you to be
part of a lie
now God's people themselves of course as
we have seen are subject to swallowing a
lie
Isaiah 9 14 therefore the Lord will cut
off from Israel head and tail branch and
rush in one day that's very serious
so many of the leaders within God's
people
are actually practicing a lie yes and
there's no place you'll be cut off
and then Isaiah tells you who they are
the Ancients and honorable he is the
head and the prophet that teaches lies
he is the tale
so we need to know what a lie is we need
to be able to deal with lies
and we are constantly surrounded we are
almost swimming
in Lies We Are huh that's the truth
for the leaders of this people says
Isaiah 9 16 caused them to ER and they
that are LED of them are destroyed
so be very careful if you hear decrees
coming from leaders or anything that
downplays the truth that's it or
statements that are being made that is
in harmony with the LIE correct
so to substitute external forms of
religion for Holiness of heart and life
is still as pleasing to the unrenewed
nature as it was in the days of these
Jewish teachers
today as then there are false spiritual
guides to whose doctrines many listen
eagerly do we have them in the church no
yes we want to get our ears tickled
it is Satan's studied effort to divert
Minds from the hope of Salvation through
faith in Christ and obedience to the law
of God
in every age the art enemy adapts his
Temptations to the prejudices or
inclinations of Those whom he's seeking
to deceive so if we look at today's
world
then we must recognize this deception
because there are thousands within the
ranks of God's people that follow a
narrative that is so blatantly obvious a
lie if you compare it to the scriptures
and you see what's that statement what
makes it so interesting is that Satan
studies the inclinations of people and
even Nations and on that he adapts his
way of attack of lying so if you have a
nation that's inclined to have a racial
problem of course that's where he's
going to focus yes and if you have
another Nation that's inclined to have
something different everything based on
lies all right now let's just take that
example that you've just mentioned let's
say you have a nation like South Africa
that has a racial divide
irrespective of where it comes from
eventually what they do and this is very
very obvious they link Christianity in
Christ to one of the races
and then you get inflammatory speeches
about the religion of a particular race
so actually it's a roundabout way of
attacking Jesus Christ and and who sits
behind it the devil the devil so that's
a lie so if you get caught up in this
whole thing you are practicing alive so
once you recognize what the aim is we
always say look at the situation
and ask yourself where is it leading
don't look at it in isolation and climb
onto a soapbox look where is it leading
and if it leads in any shape or form to
transgression of God's precepts or
denial of Jesus Christ then it is
practicing a lie and that leads to death
yes
so in Apostolic times he led the Jews to
exalt the ceremonial law and reject
Christ
at the present time he induces many
professing Christians under the pretense
of honoring Christ to cause contempt on
the moral law
and to teach that its precepts may be
transgressed with impunity
it is the duty of every servant of God
to withstand firmly and decidedly these
perverters of the faith
and by the word of Truth fearlessly to
expose their errors
that's why it's so important to the
devil to denigrate the word of God get
rid of it and that's why I infiltrate it
inside and that all these distortions
that you can't get the whole truth
correct
so should God's people lie well
obviously the Bible will have something
to say about that
Isaiah 63 verse 8 for he said surely
they are my people children that will
not lie
so he was their savior it's very
important
children that will not lie
so he was their savior so must you stand
for truth absolutely he's the savior
for those that believe the truth all
right now if you stand for truth without
even opening your mouth do you condemn
the LIE yes
oh you're 100 all right so just being
you
makes you a criminal that's it
it's criminal it's terrorism if you
stand for truth
by my action by my action
not by my words
I am
on the side of truth but they want to
condemn me for all right so let's take
Djokovic
under the present legislation
would he be regarded according to the
World Health Organization for example as
a criminal yes
he is and he's also regarded as a
terrorist according to the World Health
Organization all right
Colossians 3 verse 9 lie not one to
another seeing that you have put off the
old man with his deeds so lying and
Christ
are mutually exclusive they can never be
it's like two magnets there's no way
that they can get even close to each
other yes um the polls are yes opposite
direction yes
Zechariah 8 16. these are the things
that ye shall do speaking every man the
truth to his neighbor
execute the Judgment of Truth and peace
in your Gates that's our duty
so did the disciples lie to us
when they wrote the Bible did they lie
to us no no they did not why because
they were speaking about Jesus all right
did Jesus lied to us no no so Romans 9
verse 1 says I say the truth in Christ I
lie not my conscience also bearing me
witness in the Holy Ghost
so Paul says that what he writes is the
truth he's not lying is making a a
adamant statement I'm not lying
now Martin if you read Romans chapter 1
then he's not lying when he says there
what will happen in the last days right
is it happening yes
as in the days of no one lot all right
so where's the LIE is it what's
happening in the world which is now
politically correct or is it what the
Bible says fortunately the Bible is
truth and all this other nonsense lies
must be lies right second Corinthians 11
31 the God and father of our Lord Jesus
Christ which is blessed forevermore
knoweth that I lie not
Galatians now the things which are right
unto you behold before God I lie not is
very adamant Jesus also three times said
I tell you the truth
that's why they hate him
1 John 2 verse 21 I have not written
unto you because you know not the truth
but because you know it and that no lie
is in the truth so lying and Truth are
mutually exclusive
1 John 4 6 we are of God he that knoweth
God heareth us he that is not of God
heareth not us hereby know we the spirit
of truth and the spirit of error
so the Bible writers are very adamant
that if you do not believe what they are
saying you are living a lie
and when you live a lie it leads to
death
Jesus can't save you in a lie but this
is very serious and again why are we
talking about this because the entire
world is living a lie
that's the bottom line it's the bottom
line and you have to separate yourself
from the lie you can't be part of the
lie no come out of it and even if it's
not comfortable
because let's face it
getting out of these lies is not
comfortable no because you stand out
like a sore finger right that brings me
then to the next point do the people
actually out there in the world desire
the truth no how do you know that
because we've read it before as well
because we see it people are comfortable
in the lie because it's uncomfortable to
go according to the truth okay so what
you see on the news
that people believe and run with
could that be all lies yes how much
Faith Can you put in what the world says
when the world actually loves the LIE
let's have a look Jeremiah 5 verse 3. I
love Jeremiah for a guy sitting there in
the Quagmire
you see the thing is we can relate to
Jeremiah quite a bit yeah right oh Lord
are not Thine Eyes Upon the truth
they're stricken them
but they have not grieved
that has consumed them but they have
refused to receive correction
they have made their faces harder than a
rock they have refused to return no
matter what God does they just don't
listen
or Jeremiah 9 verse 3 and 5.
and they bend their tongues like the bow
for lies but they are not Valiant for
the truth upon the Earth for they
proceed from Evil to evil and they know
not me says the Lord Martin again who is
he speaking to well he's
speaking to the church and the leaders
in the church
and they will deceive everyone his
neighbor and will not speak the truth
they have taught their tongues to speak
lies and weary themselves to commit
iniquity
all right so is it very important that
we understand what God is trying to tell
us and is it very important that we
understand the character of God and know
God yes because it's salvational
all right how important is it to know
God John 17 verse 3 and this is life
eternal that they might Know Thee the
only true God and Jesus Christ whom thou
has sent
uh
life eternal
so if you don't know God you don't have
now if Jesus Is God and you don't know
him and you don't want to know him and
you
reject him outright
don't you forfeit eternal life yes
all right
so what does the spirit of Prophecy say
Christian experience and teachings
Christ is the perfect revelation of God
let those who desire to know God study
the work and teaching of Christ to those
who will receive him and Believe on him
he gives power to become the sons of God
how do you become a Son of God firstly
you want want to know the truth and you
want to believe on him okay
teach the knowledge of God to know God
is
eternal life
are you teaching this to your children
well are you teaching them to meet the
world standards are you getting ready
for the home that God is preparing for
you teach your children of the savior's
life death and Resurrection teach them
to study the Bible what did they want to
do get rid of the Bible
teach them to form characters that will
live through the Eternal ages we must
pray as we never have before that God
will keep and bless our children
but this is a life and death issue well
there's a portion in here that's very uh
that stands out to me are you getting
ready for the home that God is preparing
for you so what does this entail are
there any lies in heaven no I'm I'm
really longing
for the University of Heaven I I would
want to do a course in corrective
thinking
but you know where it starts that should
start now yes it starts there it starts
here already so if we want to do a
course in corrective thinking then we
should start putting away things that we
of putting off things that we should
sort out now uh-huh all right
so there are many issues that we have to
deal with and I know that we always talk
about the health issue but it's very
prominent in the world one is truth and
one is alive please make a choice
exactly please make a choice
but don't practice and limp and half a
lie no like we also said oh not even we
the Bible says there's a right arm of
the gospel and there's a right arm of
Satan's gospel yes
so will all liars be exposed fortunately
I think the answer is yes yes
Isaiah 26 verse 2 opened ye the gates
that the righteous nation which keeps
the truth may enter in
does it say knows the truth no
keep it so you know it already but you
also do it all right let's read it again
open you the gates that the righteous
nation which keepeth the truth
may enter in what this is so important
because we have
a inclination even within our church
to say God said so but it's not so
important I don't have to do it now
because the world tells me if I look at
everyone else that it's okay it's not
okay
Revelation 3 9 behold I will make them
of the synagogue of Satan which say they
are Jews in other words would say they
are believers or Christians or not but
do lie
behold I will make them to come and
worship before thy feet and to know that
I have loved thee or 21 17 and there
shall in no wise enter in anything that
defileth neither whatsoever worketh
abomination
or maketh a lie
there's no place for a lie in heaven but
they which are written in the Lamb's
Book of Life those are the ones that
will go in
all right what about revelation 22 15
for without other dogs
it's idolators non-believers
and Sorcerers and whoremongers and
murderers and idolaters and whosoever
loveth and maketh a lie
there are many people that seem to love
the lie you know this actual verse
the preceding verse says those that will
enter Heaven is those that are keeping
the Commandments but then of course like
we've seen most new translations
say wash your robes okay so let's ignore
the new translations but now if you take
the the this verse
you cannot change that verse from and
the Commandments because this verse the
sick one just following on it tells you
what will happen to the people that
don't
adhere to correct Commandments all right
Romans 1 verse 18 for the wrath of God
is revealed from Heaven against all
ungodliness and unrighteousness of men
who hold the truth in unrighteousness
but this is very serious you can
actually hold the truth in
unrighteousness
so that means you've got it but you
don't adhere to it you don't live it out
so for example if you reject
justification by faith
and embrace justification by works or
any aspect of it you are holding the
truth and unrighteousness
Isaiah 28 17 judgment also will I lay to
the line and righteousness to the
plummet and the hail shall sweep away
the Refuge of Lies I cannot wait for
that day and the water shall overflow
The Hiding Place
lies will be exposed unfortunately many
people will go through very tumultuous
times if not even death
in order to uphold the truth
so what is the truth Martin
well we've we've given the definitions
thousands of times Jesus is the truth
the word is the truth and the law is the
truth
John 8 45 and because I tell you the
you believe me not
this is God manifest In the Flesh he's
telling the people the truth and they
don't believe him do you think they'll
believe you no
no
but if the Holy Spirit gets hold of them
that's it because it's then it's also
truth
the spirit is truth because it leads you
to Jesus correct
John 8 46 which of you convinces me of
sin and if I say the truth why do you
not believe me
so I wonder if you speak truth
the chances are the majority won't
believe you no and probably even hate
you
then maybe that could be used well this
person is not very popular in what he
says maybe he's speaking the truth
laughs
and Jesus said unto him John 14 verse 6
I am the way the truth and the life no
man comes unto the father but by me
it's either truth or it's a lie you know
I always tell the story I I read this
verse once in Germany and somebody got
up in the audience and started screaming
at me that I was being discriminatory
because what of all the other religions
then I I gave that silly example
I said
I have three children
and if there are seven billion people in
the world and half of them are men
then statistically the chances that I am
the father of the children is one in
three and a half billion
but ignoring the statistics I'm
absolutely certain that I am the father
of my children so whether the statistics
say so or not
I'm still the father of those children
it's just the truth so whether or not
you want to believe this it's still the
truth it's the truth whether you like it
or not if he is God and if he is the
creator
then he's the only one that can give you
eternal life that's it
nobody else can because nobody has life
within himself to give it to you yeah
so you either take it or you leave it if
you don't want to believe it then follow
the others but the ways lead to death
now is that going to be popular that
statement No that's hate speech what
would this fellow behind us on the
screen say about that he's going to tell
us get rid of these guys okay
now John 18 37 is always so interesting
to me pilate therefore said unto him
ought thou a King Jesus answered thou
sayest that I am a king
to this end was I born and for this
cause came into the world that I should
bear witness unto the truth everyone
that is of the truth here is my voice
then pilate asks them what is truth
and then he walks away
and he doesn't get an answer
he's he walks away
the greatest question that he can
possibly ask and he doesn't wait for an
answer so he's lost yeah
isn't that the same that's happening
today in the world correct
Psalms 117 verse 2 for his merciful
kindness is great towards us and the
truth of the Lord endureth forever
praise ye the Lord you cannot change the
truth
and if Jesus said I tell you the truth
nobody comes to the father except by me
then
that's just the fact okay like I'm the
father of my children whether you like
it or not
then said Jesus to those Jews which
believed on him if you continue in my
word then you are my disciples indeed
there's another very important thing if
you want to be a disciple of Jesus
your religion must be word based
true and you cannot only be the harbor
of the truth you have to actually
live it out as well all right so
somebody who says if you preach Jesus
you're a you're a criminal or somebody
says if you follow the word
you are a criminal
and the the word should be banned
then they're Liars you see we're living
in that time now the problem now is like
we've mentioned just just earlier this
if you now stand up and say Jesus is the
only way to heaven
you are pronouncing hate speech Yes it's
hate speech
John 8 verse 32 and you shall know the
truth and the truth shall make you free
so Martin does that entail knowing Jesus
yes because he's the truth does that
mean keeping the Commandments yes
because all your Commandments are truth
yes does that means that you follow
everything that the word says 100 so
what does that do to all those isms that
are in the world out there
put you in conflict with them put you in
conflict with them the bottom line is
Jesus is the truth
and the one who tells you the truth
the serpent is the liar
and he's the one that convinces the
world
that the LIE should be ostracized
persecuted condemned and preferably put
to death yes eliminated
um
may God help us let's pray
Heavenly Father
help us to study the word
to internalize truth that we may be able
to controvert the LIE
help us to stand for truth
when the world buys the LIE
and help us Lord to be instruments in
your hands to point people to the truth
that they may turn their backs upon the
LIE is my prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you